if you're a fan of The Real Housewives
shows you know the man behind the
franchise Andy Cohen he's a New York
Times bestselling author has his own
radio channel but his real baby is watch
what happens live our Carly Steele spent
a day in the life of Andy Cohen
hey UT we're on our way to watch what
happens live me and my buddy right buddy
welcome to Andy's world the Bravo
Executive hosts the only live show in
late night this is very cool this is
like the I inner sanctum Clubhouse
within the clubhouse a little dressing
room the show started online and has
exploded into one of the most fun romps
on television I saw my brother smoking
out of a bong
before one of the Oscars won't say which
good um and you take a little bit yeah
kid maybe it's the alcohol if I invited
you over to my house at 11 o'clock the
first thing I would do would be to make
you a drink
Tom Hardy there is not all but that man
would be excluded from have you ever had
a moment where you feel like oh I've
gone a little bit far yes you ever been
with a lady no I have not I was like oh
my god I think I've just ruined
everything
good Cameron whose game you ever been
with a lady I am yes I have been with a
lady yeah more than once I asked Lady
Gaga if she had ever done Molly I mean
I've done to them I mean I like rent my
raver days I've taken on bail fees with
both Kim Kardashian and Khloe Kardashian
which is a butt selfie oh my god
watch what happens live is celebrating
its 1,000th show next week worth an
estimated 15 million dollars and he also
has his own Sirius XM radio channel okay
this is my ritual here radio Andy I got
the post I got the times I have my
everything bagel recent guest Susan
Lucci was his first celeb interview back
in 1987 when he was a sophomore at
Boston University out she comes the
double doors full-length fur coat red
knit dress when Andy first wrote that
letter when he was a student at BU and I
was on All My Children
something about him I've told him
there's something just jumped off the
page Andy is a non-stop ball of energy
every minute of the day you know what
it's all fun for me I'm passionate about
everything I'm doing I am living the
life I always dreamed that I would be
living so I pinch myself every day you
know one of the guests already lined up
for his 1080 get she'll tell you
anything I'm sure if she could she would
give birth on stage yeah the girl has no
fear